a voluntary recall of millions of
breathing machines used mainly to treat
sleep apnea has many users wondering if
they've been inhaling cancer-causing
toxins in their sleep the manufacturer
phillips recalled the cpap machines
because of possible health effects at
least 25 million u.s adults have sleep
apnea a potentially serious sleep
disorder in which breathing repeatedly
stops and starts u.s senator richard
blumenthal is demanding answers about
how many people are affected by the
recall and what phillips is doing to
help them our consumer investigative
correspondent anna warner heard from
some frustrated cpap users anna good
morning
good morning jerica yeah you know people
who use these machines literally need
them at night to breathe but they now
face the choice of continuing to use a
machine that the company says could
actually hurt their health or going
without which means they won't be
getting a good night's sleep
there were times where i would literally
fall asleep mid-sentence talking to
someone because i was so exhausted from
not getting sleep the night before james
colbert says that was his life 13 years
ago before he started using a cpap
machine including for the last two years
the phillips dream station
i actually woke up refreshed
and could go throughout the course of my
day
with
you know a ton of energy that i needed
for work or you know time with my family
for people like colbert who have sleep
apnea breathing repeatedly stops and
starts throughout the night a continuous
positive airway pressure or cpap machine
pushes a steady stream of air into a
user's nose and mouth keeping airways
open but in june manufacturer phillips
voluntarily recalled millions of its
popular cpap machines saying sound
dampening foam used in the dream station
may degrade into particles and off-gas
chemicals the fda says breathing those
in could result in serious injury which
can be life-threatening or cause
permanent impairment ranging from
irritation to asthma even toxic or
carcinogenic effects it's caused a lot
of anxiety dr david clayman directs the
sleep center at ucsf and says many of
his patients have recalled machines
so what are you telling your patients to
do i'm advising the more severe patients
to stay on cpap
and then i'm to some degree in the
milder cases letting them choose because
i also feel uncomfortable with saying i
can't know that this is safe
josefa cozira of lehighton pennsylvania
relied on her dream station to sleep so
she could provide round-the-clock care
for her son camille who has muscular
dystrophy she needs to
bathe me dress me
feed me and
have a lot of exercises
to do during the
days but since the recall she says her
doctor advised her not to use the
machine and she's struggling without it
i'm very tired
very slow joseph how much sleep do you
get
without the machine
when i don't have machine now
two hours three hours her son says
medicare turned her down for a
replacement machine and she can't afford
to spend hundreds of dollars to buy a
new one you need this well she called
several times to her insurance
medicare
and they're saying
because it hasn't been five years
even though it's not her fault
at all
they're not willing to
pay for
a new machine phillips now says it will
replace or repair devices within
approximately 12 months once the fda
approves a solution it's unclear how
many patients have suffered health
effects the company says it received
complaints on
0.03 percent of its machines in 2020
including some the fda sent about the
presence of black debris or particles in
some machines phillips said its own
testing revealed possible risks which
raises questions for dr clayman is this
just the tip of the iceberg or is this
all there is as for james colbert he
says the risks of not wearing the
machine are greater than possible
unknown health effects so he's
continuing to use his i cannot
afford to not use it
because i would get so little sleep and
if i slept without it i would stop
breathing so many times during the
course of the night but he has a message
for phillips to tell me that it could
take up to a year that's a year that i
could be putting myself in jeopardy you
know people just cannot afford to wait
12 months for a resolution
well colbert has also now joined a
lawsuit against the company he says
mainly to try to push them to act faster
on this problem uh phillips did not
respond to our request for comment on
this lawsuit there is another issue
going on here too which is that many
people who have the machines use an
ozone cleaning system to clean them and
that may be degrading this sound
abatement foam even faster and jerica
just to add another wrinkle to this
whole thing in april the company came
out with another machine called the
dream station 2 which it says is not
affected by this recall so
we've heard from a lot of people on this
who are very very upset and frustrated
dealing with this such important
reporting and i didn't realize it
affected so many people thank you